Time to kick ass gonna need a soundtrack
ship favorites playlist track one
using you as a human shield you said it
you said the thing i thought you were doing
having a bit of trouble with your
car sanchez right now gene just
do a die hard what does that mean sneak around
use air vents you've never seen die hard i'm
17 no i've never seen die hard well neither
did the guy in die hard so you're nailing it
this is an obvious trap we have
to go do i want you to say wubble
up a dub dub at the end but but
screw that right yeah we're not
rick and morty new season premieres sunday
september 4th at 11pm Welcome back everyone this
will be my rick and morty season six trailer video
rick and morty is finally back justin roiland said
it's probably gonna be the most canon season that
they've done in a while that just means that most
of the episodes will be canon-based episodes
instead of like the one-off episodes that they
did a lot during season four and season five i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes just like i
did for previous seasons be sure to subscribe
to get them all i'll do a special rick and
morty giveaway when that starts too with him just
clarifying that he felt like season six was way
stronger as a season just all the episodes
were way better than season five episodes
and when he started talking about them doing
way more canon-based episodes that just means
them sort of addressing the big cliffhanger
at the end of the season five finale where
evil morty successfully destroyed the citadel
of rix and its ability to separate the central
finite curve from the rest of the multiverse
the rest of the other timelines and realities
and they just ended with him excitedly entering
those other realities it didn't seem like he had
any future evil intent or anything like that like
he just did what he did because he hated the idea
of the central finite curve so much i go into
much greater detail about the ramifications of
what happened during my rick and morty season
5 episode 10 video so i'll add a link for that
at the end of this and down in the description
below if you want to learn more about that and
all the big backstory reveals but the central
finite curve was basically like the subset of
realities where rick was supreme and he just found
a way to basically create this barrier separating
it from the rest of the multiverse which means
heading into rick and morty season six episode one
there's just way more potential threats out there
that they had previously been protected from
like there were already basic threats that rick
dealt with during the first five seasons but now
there's the idea that there are infinite other
unknowns infinite other permutations and things
that could come to attack them which sort of flows
with the idea of them using the paranoid song
for the trailer because even though rick's always
been a paranoid person now he has a much greater
reason to be paranoid it looks like space beth is
gonna be much bigger part of season six i think
they said that previously she was around a little
bit for season five but it was really more like a
quick tag scene i think they're gonna do way more
with her during season six i think the footage is
mostly from the first couple of episodes i don't
think it's from the back half of the season
because most of the scenes just seem like they're
from a couple episodes just cut up across the
trailer you notice in this first fight scene here
when he queues up the paranoid song like he queues
it up as if it's a song that he likes and is
on his favorites playlist jerry is sitting here
wearing morty's trademark outfit like he's wearing
the trademark yellow shirt and blue pants but they
don't fit him quite right like he's wearing
morty's actual clothes so we'll find out why
during this scene when he's scanning him with this
device here while he's wearing morty's clothes
this device actually looks like the same
scanner that they used in the ghostbusters movie
it looks like in their house here in this scene
the household appliances have all transformed into
weapons attacking them this is like the washer and
the dryer basically rick secretly puts weapons and
defenses built into all parts of the house so
this shouldn't be too much of a surprise but
it just seems like the house itself kind of goes
rogue on them the red eyes on them kind of make
them seem like they're inspired by a cylons from
battlestar galactica which flows with the idea
of robots gaining sentience and attacking them
there's also some freaky experiment gone wrong
with all their groceries in the middle of the
floor here too that's probably part of the idea
that the appliances like the fridge for instance
transforms into a giant weapon to attack them
spacebeth comes back to join them while it looks
like rick is doing some experiment with his portal
fluid apparently in this episode something is
happening to them that's going to make the family
vanish from this particular reality you see them
go back to blitz and chips again and have a bunch
of die hard references he literally calls it
out in the episode and they make a joke about
how some are super young so she just hasn't seen
a lot of 80s movies like i haven't seen die hard
i'm only 17 years old whatever's going on during
this episode too they also have to put themselves
in that roy game that'll become a much bigger
thing in like the next 10 years like you'll see
kids come along and be like what are you talking
about no i haven't seen the original star wars
movies even tom holland mr spiderman himself said
that he has not seen the original star wars movies
don't you feel old now there's another episode
where they go up against a bunch of tech based
aliens and when they duck under these shields
this kind of seems like an upgrade to rick's
regular ship it could be space best ship because
you see her driving in one scene but there are
like a bunch of other scenes in different episodes
where you see him using it and some of the parts
just do look like nicer versions of the same
parts that rick has on his ship like it's got
the saucer design in the back the seats seem like
the same seats just a little bit nicer the layout
is pretty much the same and the drives on the
side still kind of look like the trash cans
but apparently r.i.p because morty trips and winds
up causing it to self-destruct so we'll see if
he winds up rebuilding this version but it also
might be them just trying to create a new ship so
they can sell that new toy justin roiland is the
master of creating what they call toyetic stuff
in the episodes things that you can turn into
toys like it's a very star wars concept like
when you think of star wars introducing all these
crazy new things you think about them selling all
the toys based on that stuff in real life justin
roiland is also this huge collector like you can
see behind him in his house here he has all this
stuff that he's collected i've got a little bit of
rick and morty merch i even used to use a banner
for rick and morty behind me in all the videos
that i did a couple years ago it's been a while
since i've used that though it looks like summer
has some kind of body modification that gives
her water-based powers allowing her to have x-23
wolverine powers with the two claws x-23 is just
a little bit different even though she's meant to
be a clone of wolverine she has two claws in her
arms and one claw in each of her feet so she still
has three claws like wolverine it's just that
they swap two of them to put them in the feet
they also have another scene where rick shows off
all of his body modifications and hidden weapons
they've used this trick before like he hides
weapons and he changes his body parts all
the time but i love the idea here that he's got a
bunch of lo-fi weapons mixed with really advanced
looking weapons like he's got an energy sword
a blaster some kind of crazy arc reactor weapon
an energy chain but he's also got this magic base
voodoo doll and just a regular broken bottle just
trying to cover all his bases in case the energy
based weapons don't work when they're escaping in
the family car this is from that same episode
where the washer and dryer the other household
appliances transform into robots to attack them
this seems like a much larger one so it might be
like the fridge or some other giant appliance they
have in the house some are stealing the cop car
on par with her personality she's been way more
hardcore than morty the past few seasons which
is why when rick gets tired of morty moralizing on
him so much he'll just take summer on adventures
instead usually they have a way of bringing that
back where like summer will do something really
stupid and get them into trouble that they'll have
to save so they have a way of balancing out morty
in summer like morty will do smart things and
really dumb things at the same time summer is also
the same way like she does smart stuff but also
really really dumb stuff there's a lot of footage
of rick and jerry so it seems like there might be
just like a rick and jerry adventure during one
of the episodes this seems like another 2001 space
odyssey type of adventure like during season three
whirly dirly conspiracy rick and jerry traveled
through that open portal experiencing the effects
of the temporal forces and it turned into this
super psychedelic mind trip and just like the 2001
space odyssey movie it zooms in on his eyeball
and you can see it reflected they bring back
gene for another joke like every time he shows up
they just use them as a punching bag everything
okay here mind your own goddamn business gene
i'm having a conversation with my mother here
what what is this guy doing wait what but you
said get out of here weirdo that sweetheart
can you give me a minute i'm trying to
steer around the bodies of our neighbors
that felt like gene that's on you bet i also think
they killed him off in a previous season or at
least ran him over with a car love the gasoline
factory joke like this is the same episode where
they're escaping with the robot appliances in
the cop car summer stole just winds up jumping
into the gasoline factory just causing the
biggest explosion you've ever seen and they
end the trailer with them making fun of themselves
again like rick and morty making fun of rick and
morty because they do advertisements all the time
like they sell themselves out all the time come
on rick it's three in the morning why do you keep
selling us out bear gloves swagger and pure spore
can't make it stop morty you're gonna smell
great tomorrow 4 000. they also spent like
most of season 5 doing those wendy commercials i
never actually made it to a real life wendy's when
they rebranded the menu items as the rick
and morty items if you did let me know in
the comments i think they learned their lesson
from all the craziness with the szechuan sauce
the other big thing you may have seen is there's
a special promo that they did before they dropped
the trailer about this secret egg hatching in
something called the secret citadel and there's
gonna be like some sort of tie-in that they do
during rick and morty season six so it might be
like a tamagotchi situation where like the egg
will hatch when season six starts and it just
has something to do with the end of season five
like they just continue with that story line with
some tie-in content so post all your theories
what you think that this thing is all about
but if you spotted any other huge easter eggs in
the trailer that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments there will
be another rick and morty season 6 trailer before
episode starts so i will do a new bonus video
when we get more footage there's going to be a
ton of really cool episodes every week very soon
because i'll be doing she-hulk episodes star wars
and or episodes house of the dragon episodes lord
of the rings and rick and morty episodes all those
shows will only overlap all together at the same
time for like a very brief period but for like a
hot second we're gonna have five different banger
shows all airing episodes at the exact same time
thankfully they'll all be on different days
i don't know if i'd be able to do videos like
this if they were all on the same day that'd be
kind of a nightmare everyone click here for my
new she-hulk world war hulk trailer video and
click here for all my rick and morty episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!